[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday july 29th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
facebook parent meta has been trying to
weather storm after storm lately
economic conditions like rising
inflation are weighing on advertising
revenue competitors are becoming an
increasing threat for users attention
meta's leadership is changing and
regulators have their eyes trained on
the company
and those are just some of the most
recent struggles
on the company's earnings call on
wednesday ceo mark zuckerberg tried to
reassure investors that meta was
prepared for the headwinds
we're focused on making the long-term
investments that will position us to be
stronger coming out of this downturn
including our work on our discovery
engine and reels our new ads
infrastructure and
the metaverse
and we're also focused on being rigorous
about measuring returns and sizing these
investments correctly but it's unclear
how successful those reassurances have
really been
meta shares are down and facebook and
instagram users who are experiencing
changes to the platforms have been
voicing their displeasure
joining us to discuss all of this is our
reporter salvador rodriguez
hey sal thanks for being here
yeah thanks for having me as always
so we heard a clip from mark zuckerberg
talking about the company you know
wanting to focus on their discovery
engine and reels you know those changes
to the platforms but also their ad
infrastructure and the metaverse so
lay this out for us what kind of
situation has the company found itself
in and why are these the areas that it's
focusing on
so meta is basically in a position that
it has been in twice before in its
history and that is that it is having to
basically reinvent and very much pivot
its company for the sake of going
through you know an existential threat
we saw it in 2012 when the company was
getting ready to ipo
at that time social media was very much
shifting from being
web-based desktop-based to mobile first
and the company
really had to revamp its mobile apps and
spend a billion dollars acquiring
instagram we saw it again in the period
between 2016 and 2018
when they had to
essentially copy snapchat's signature
feature stories
and they launched that on instagram and
later the rest of their apps and after
that they had to monetize that feature
to really just kind of
go to where the puck was going
and now we're seeing it happen yet again
and this time it's with tick tock and
with short form video but on top of all
that the company is also dealing with a
number of other macroeconomic factors
that are making the situation
much more difficult that of course being
inflation
you know the impact of apple's privacy
changes to facebook's advertising
business you know the looming recession
all those things are creating a really
difficult you can even call it a perfect
storm type situation for meta
so how is meta saying it's dealing with
these challenges
yeah so it's trying to do a number of
things to overcome this
it's long-term solution is to
build out the metaverse which is really
just a buzzword for
virtual reality this is something that
they've been working on for a while and
it's a key priority for them they want
people to have vr headsets and use that
as one of their main forms of computing
the reason for that is because
what meta lacks is its own hardware
device and when you don't have that as a
tech company you're always at the mercy
of someone else so they really want
virtual reality to take off and that's
their solution for the long term in the
short term they still need to get their
advertising business back in order and
they need to ensure that they don't
lose users to tick-tock so what they're
doing is essentially building out reels
which is essentially their version of
tick-tock
and not only are they building it out
but they're really emphasizing it
yeah let's talk about that a bit because
adam moseri the head of instagram
addressed some of the complaints about
changes the platform has made recently
including the increasing number of
videos and changing the kinds of posts
that users see he addressed this in a
video on tuesday let's take a listen
now i want to be clear we're going to
continue to support photos it's part of
our heritage i love photos i know a lot
of you out there love photos too that
said i need to be honest i do believe
that more and more of instagram is going
to become video over time
so that video was posted on tuesday
flash forward to thursday and missouri
is saying the company is walking back
some of those changes what did he
announce yeah so missouri in an
interview that was published on thursday
with platformer he said that the company
is actually going to roll back and
rethink some of these changes
the two that are getting rolled back is
a redesign that was being tested where
users were going to see photos and
videos in full screen so very similar to
the design of tick tock and the other
thing that is going to be rolled back to
a certain extent is the number of posts
that users see
based on ai recommendations from
accounts that they don't already follow
so these were two of the biggest changes
that they had announced this year and it
seems like instagram is really
rethinking just how much it can throw at
its users all at once
but what was made clear by misery in
this interview with platformer is that
these rollbacks are only temporary so
instagram users should still expect that
these changes will come down at some
point down the road
what does this mean in terms of their
efforts to get the the creator economy
and we heard you know some famous people
kylie jenner kim kardashian say they
they didn't like the changes that were
being implemented how do we expect that
to to impact instagram's decisions
yeah well in this interview that
missouri did with platformer he very
much addressed creators and talked about
how creators expect something stable you
know if they're gonna make your platform
their livelihood they need to understand
how it works have an understanding or an
expectation of which of their posts will
succeed and therefore be able to make an
income from this my favorite quote from
his interview with platformer
he said change is hard i also want to
acknowledge if you spend an hour at your
desk every day talking to your friends
and reading or watching tv and then i
come by and i just rearranged everything
without telling you you'd be pretty
pissed so i think we need to do a better
job making sure it's clear why something
is better in explaining something before
it happens so we don't surprise people
and i think that tells you everything
that you need to know where missouri and
the rest of meta they have so many
stakeholders that they need to answer to
whether it's your everyday user
you know creators or
trying to attract younger users who are
going off to tick tock and that's the
problem when your user base gets as big
as it is you have a lot of people that
you need to make happy and it's you know
it's it's very hard to do that
all right that's our reporter salvador
rodriguez thanks so much for joining us
sal thanks for having me
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week our producer is julie chang we
had editorial support from scott
salloway our supervising producer is
chris sinsley our executive producer is
kateri yocum and i'm your host zoe
thomas thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
[Music]
[Music]
you